pour shopenhauer l'air frais et le
secret de la santé ce matin de 1860 sa
femme de ménage ouvre donc comme
d'habitude la fenêtre de la pièce de
retour quelques minutes plus tard elle
retrouve le philosophe de 72 ans sans
vie dans le canapé le courant d'air la
tuer mais il n'a pas souffert il a l'air
paisible lui qui avait tant écrit sur la
mort il n'en n'avait pas peur il a avoué
un de ses plus proches amis ce qui le
terrifiait que les fruits de son esprit
soient corrompus par les profs de philo
[Musique]
la particularité de shopenhauer c'est
qu'il est le philosophe le plus lu en
dehors du monde académique il a eu une
énorme influence dans la pensée
occidentale Nietzsche Freud pour ne
citer que on puisait chez Schopenhauer
il a aussi inspiré les plus grands
artistes européens du 19e siècle par
exemple le compositeur allemand Richard
Wagner ou les romanciers Maupassant et
Kafka mais il a beau être très populaire
et avoir écrit sur à peu près tous les
sujets il n'a pas eu de disciple à
l'université contrairement à quand et à
Hegel les deux autres géants de la
philosophie allemande de l'époque en
même temps Schopenhauer a eu des mots
très durs contre les profs et les
universitaires il dit qu'ils ont
abandonné l'amour de la vérité qu'il se
prostitue c'est ça qui est exceptionnel
dans le destin de Schopenhauer comment
devenir un des plus grands noms de la
philosophie en insultant les gens qui
font le classement après il y a beaucoup
d'autres choses très intéressantes dans
la vie de ce philosophe des choses qui
nous permettent de mieux comprendre la
naissance des grandes idées
pénétration et leur influence dans la
société je vais donc vous raconter 10
anecdotes étonnantes et révélatrices sur
le destin de shopenhauer je consacre une
des dernières anecdotes à sa vie
amoureuse qui ne ressemble pas du tout
vous allez voir à celle d'un philosophe
Dower passe souvent pour le penseur du
pessimisme celui qui détruit toutes nos
illusions sur l'existence et qui nous
montre que la vie n'a pas de sens par
exemple Michel Houellebecq qui ne
respire pas le bonheur dit que le monde
comme volonté comme représentation
l’œuvre majeure de Schopenhauer a été
pour lui une révélation comme on peut
s'y attendre shopenhauer était lui-même
dépressif mais il n'a connu aucun grand
malheur qui est causé son état en fait
il en reconnaît lui-même l’origine
c'était l'éditeur et ça lui vient de son
père Henri fleuris shopenhauer a tout
pour être heureux une belle femme
intelligente et deux enfants qui
montrent des dispositions
intellectuelles une entreprise prospère
qui lui permet de mener un train de vie
très confortable un réseau personnel
dans la bourgeoisie cosmopolite
européenne des voyages pour satisfaire
sa curiosité mais voilà il est comme sa
mère la grand-mère paternelle du
philosophe il a une grosse tendance à la
dépression pour sa femme la mère du
philosophe qui est elle extravertie et
plutôt optimiste pour elle et c'est un
vrai poids au quotidien et puis ça finit
mal le père de Schopenhauer se renferme
sur lui-même il devient fou puis il
retrouver flottant dans les eaux glacées
du canal derrière la maison familiale le
philosophe a 17 ans ce que montre cette
anecdote c'est que le pessimisme de la
pensée de Schopenhauer exprime
probablement son penchant personnel
héréditaire à la dépression comme son
père je peux naware est souvent
dépressif anxieux et mélancolique en
plus il reste dans la solitude et si lui
n'est pas passé à l'acte il a réfléchi à
la question du suicide pendant toute sa
vie
l'obsession d'un écrivain c'est de vivre
de sa plume celle d'un penseur c'est de
vivre de sa pensée le bon plan c'est
depuis qu'il y a des universités d'être
prof à l'Université comme ça le penseur
a un revenu fixe garanti il donne
quelques cours et ça lui laisse le temps
de créer une oeuvre c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que fonctionne les deux autres
géants de la philosophie allemande de
l'époque quand et Eagle mais shopenhauer
n'est pas dans la même situation parce
que depuis la mort de son père il a
hérité d'un bon pactole shopenhawer est
rentier alors il n'a pas de quoi
intégrer la jet-set mais il peut vivre
confortablement jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours sans travailler en plus il n'aura
ni femme ni enfant à charge il n'a pas
besoin comme Spinoza deux siècles plutôt
de donner des cours particuliers et de
travailler comme artisan opticien pour
survivre et ça ne risque pas d'arriver
parce que shopenhauer gère
consciencieusement son capital il prend
peu de risques il diversifie ses
investissements par exemple il suit le
conseil de sa mère et de sa sœur en
plaçant une partie de son héritage chez
un banquier réputé de gangsk ville qui
appartient à l'époque au royaume de
Prusse et contrairement à elle il
défendra agressivement son argent
lorsque l'investissement être un échec
10 ans plus tard le banquier arrive à
berner la mer et la soeur qui accepte de
perdre une grosse partie de leur argent
mais le philosophe lui ne se laisse pas
faire parce qu'il comprend que le
banquier a le moyen de le rembourser
donc il lui met la pression et il
réussit à récupérer son argent deux ans
plus tard on ne s'attend pas ça de la
part d'un philosophe n'est-ce pas mais
la propension à la dépression n'est pas
la seule chose qu'il a hérité de son
père il a également hérité de son
intelligence économique il y a un autre
enseignement plus important à tirer de
cette anecdote la liberté financière de
Schopenhauer lui donne la liberté
intellectuelle il peut penser et
s'exprimer sans avoir à plaire à des
clients à l'université à l'église ou à
l'état et ça ça fait toute la différence
à 25 ans shopenhauer vient de publier
son essai de la quadruple racine du
principe de raison suffisante qui est
tiré de sa thèse de doctorat et c'est à
propos de ce livre que ce produit un
énième accrochage avec sa mère elle lui
demande si c'est un manuel pour les
pharmaciens il lui répond que ce livre
sera encore lu qu'en plus un seul de ses
écrits à elle ne sera disponible pas
même dans une décharge mais c'est sa
mère qui clôte l'accrochage en lui
rétorquant que tous les exemplaires
imprimés de son livre à lui seront
encore disponibles autrement dit aucun
exemplaire ne sera jamais écoulé oui ça
ne ressemble pas aux accrochages que
nous avons avec nos parents parce que
c'est un accrochage entre deux auteurs
la mère de Schopenhauer johanna est un
écrivain reconnu pendant une décennie
elle est l'autrice la plus populaire
d'Allemagne au point que ces livres
connaissent des rééditions cela fait que
pendant longtemps shopenhauer n'est pas
connu comme le philosophe Arthur
Schopenhauer mais comme le fils de la
romancière Johanna shopenhauer c'est
pour ça qu'il est jaloux mais la vérité
c'est qu'il est le fils de sa mère c'est
elle qui lui transmet son goût et son
talent pour les idées elle est une femme
très cult qui a été élevé dans les
valeurs des lumières elle a lu le
meilleur des littératures anglaises et
françaises de l'époque et puis après la
mort de son mari elle fréquentera les
intellectuels les plus en vue elle a une
influence encore plus précise sur
shopenhauer à l'adolescence elle lui
donne des conseils de style elle
l'encourage à choisir ses mots avec soin
pour s'exprimer le plus clairement
possible or le style c'est un trait
distinctif de l'oeuvre de Schopenhauer
il s'exprime de manière bien plus
intelligible que les autres philosophes
allemands de l'époque il apporte
beaucoup d'attention à la pureté de la
langue parce qu'il considère que la
clarté est un indice de la vérité
philosophique il attaque d'ailleurs ses
contemporains sur ce terrain surtout
égal il les accusent de dissimuler la
médiocrité de leurs pensées sous un
style technique incompréhensible ce qui
assemble des phrases pénibles obscures
enchevêtrés et équivoque ne savent
certainement pas bien ce qu'ils veulent
dire ils n'ont qu'une conscience obtuse
qui aspire à une idée souvent aussi ils
veulent se dissimuler à eux-mêmes et
dissimuler aux autres qu'ils n'ont en
réalité rien à dire ils veulent à
l'instar de fiches
ING et Eagle paraître savoir ce qu'ils
ne savent pas penser ce qu'ils ne
pensent pas et dire ce qu'ils ne disent
pas bref ce que montre cette anecdote
c'est que dans le cas de Schopenhauer
comme dans beaucoup d'autres cas le
génie a été semé par les parents
mais comme l'a montré Bourdieu il n'y a
pas que le talent des parents qui
avantage les enfants il y a surtout le
capital social shopenhauer bénéficie
bien sûr des contacts de son père dans
le monde économique mais ce n'est pas ce
capital social qui va lui servir c'est
le réseau de sa mère la grande
romancière qui va lui servir après la
mort de son mari elle s'établit à Weimar
la capitale culturelle l'Athènes
allemande entre guillemets de l'époque
elle y organise des soirées que
fréquente les intellectuelles et les
artistes les plus en vus et du coup
lorsque son fils se rend accessoires il
peut rencontrer ses hommes c'est bien
sûr un avantage énorme pour un étudiant
qui a une ambition intellectuelle
shopenhauer rencontre en particulier
l’auteur qu'on associe à la langue
allemande comme on dit que le français
et la langue de Molière Goeth comment
est-ce que sa mère a réussi à l'avoir à
ses soirées et bien comme Goethe s'est
marié avec sa domestique les autres
soirées n'acceptent pas sa femme mais
Johanna chopenhauer elle est moins
regardante si Goeth lui a donné son nom
dittel on peut bien lui donner une tasse
de thé du coup avec la présence du génie
de la littérature allemande les soirées
de la mère de Schopenhauer ATT des
personnalités importantes au début
Schopenhauer n'osent pas déranger Goethe
il le regarde de loin plein d'admiration
Goeth est avec quand le héros
intellectuel de shopenhauer avec le
temps le fils et l'ami de la mère se
rapproche et le grand écrivain se rend
compte de l'intelligence du jeune homme
alors ils sont fait un allié pour
promouvoir sa théorie des couleurs qui
est une réfutation de la théorie des
couleurs de Newton mais l'ambition est
l'indépendance intellectuelle de
schopenhaware le font sortir du rôle
auquel le grand écrivain voulait le
cantonner shopenhauer se permet de
suggérer des corrections à Goeth il se
sert même de la théorie des couleurs du
grand écrivain autrement dit de
l'autorité intellectuelle de Goethe pour
promouvoir sa propre philosophie ce que
révèle cette anecdote c'est que
shopenhauer a évolué au moins durant une
partie de sa vie dans le milieu culturel
idéal pour devenir un grand penseur il
était dans l'orbite de grands
intellectuels et grâce au statut de sa
mère il pouvait même se permettre de
leur demander des faveurs des lettres de
recommandation leur avis sur ses propres
textes etc
a beau avoir bénéficié du capital social
de sa mère son destin était loin d'être
tout tracé parce qu'à l'époque
philosophe n'est pas vraiment un métier
et puis parce qu'on ne choisit pas son
métier aussi librement qu'aujourd'hui le
père de Schopenhauer est un marchand en
prospère donc il prévoit que son fils
sera marchand il reprendra l'affaire
familiale tout simplement à
l'adolescence son père le place dans la
meilleure école privée de Hambourg qui
prépare aux carrières commerciales mais
au cours de ces années le jeune
Schopenhauer se rend compte qu'il a du
goût pour le monde des idées et le
directeur de l'école lui confirme qu'il
peut être plus qu'un marchand qu'il a un
potentiel intellectuel bon comme vous
l'imaginez son père ne se dit pas ah
génial mon fils veut faire philosophe
non même sa mère prend peur parce que
les parents ne veulent pas que
shopenhauer tombe dans la pauvreté des
universités et des artistes mais
étonnamment son père est tolérant il
donne le choix à son fils de 15 ans soit
il accompagne ses parents dans le grand
voyage qu'ils vont faire en Europe tout
au long du printemps et il promet de
continuer sa formation de marchand au
retour du voyage soit il renonce au
voyage et il apprend le latin en vue
universitaire pendant que son en Europe
Schopenhauer hésite et il choisit le
voyage donc normalement il devait finir
marchand et il va tenir sa promesse même
après la mort de son père il travaille
dur comme apprenti pendant deux ans mais
avec le temps l'absence de son père
renforce le désir de renoncer à sa
promesse si sa mère est ouverte à la
possibilité elle a peur même avec sa
rente son fils n'aura pas assez d'argent
pour faire vivre une famille dans
l'aisance il devra peut-être prostituer
son talent pour survivre et puis à la
fin de l'adolescence il est peut-être
tout simplement trop tard pour changer
de projet professionnel mais la mère de
Schopenhauer est rassurée par un de ses
amis il y a des universitaires de renom
qui ont choisi leur carrière encore plus
tard et l'essentiel c'est que son fils
soit certains de sa vocation et qu'il
soit prêt à faire les efforts
nécessaires c'est donc à 19 ans que
shopenhauer embrasse son destin
l'événement décisif c'est bien sûr le
suicide de son père il a fallu que le
marchand meurt pour que naissent le
philosophe
imaginez Hegel qui fait passer un oral à
chopenhauer et bien en fait ça c'est
réellement produit en 1820 shopenhauer
qui a 32 ans vient d'être engagé à
l'université de Berlin donne une
conférence d'essai devant des membres du
corps enseignant dont Eagle qui a lui 50
ans or le climat est déjà tendu parce
que shopenhauer a demandé à programmer
ses cours en même temps que ceux de
Eagle ce qui est donc une manière de se
présenter comme son concurrent direct et
même de prétendre lui voler ses élèves
alors que Eagle et la star de l'époque
il est un peu le procès officiel de
l'Allemagne donc ça ne rate pas il y a
un accrochage après la présentation de
Schopenhauer Eagle lui demande s'il
considère les fonctions animales comme
des causes et Schopenhauer le reprend
sur la définition du concept de fonction
animale lui connaît la définition
scientifique moderne pas Eagle
Schopenhauer dira à ses amis qu'il a
révélé l'ignorance scientifique de Eagle
malgré cette accrochage et gueule par
rancunier vote en faveur du jeune
philosophe alors même qu'il sait qu'il
veut lui voler la vedette mais voilà il
n'avait rien à craindre le cours de
Schopenhauer est un échec complet seul 5
étudiants sont présents conférence
contre plusieurs centaines au cours de
hegels si bien que shopenhauer ne se
donne pas la peine d'aller au bout du
cursus prévu il ne percera jamais les
quelques années où il officie à
l'université alors net en lui une
véritable haine pourrait gueule qu'il
voit comme le responsable de son échec
académique ETA toute sa vie et il ne
cessera de dénoncer l'escroquerie de la
philosophie égélienne en revanche Hegel
de son côté ne fera jamais rien pour
nuire à la carrière académique de
Schopenhauer comme je vous l'ai dit il a
voté en sa faveur au cours d'essai et il
accepte sa concurrence en fait il ne se
sent pas du tout menacé cette anecdote
montre comme d'autres le caractère de
chien de Schopenhauer il est très peu
conciliant il va facilement au conflit
et puis cette rivalité avec Hegel révèle
aussi l'ambition intellectuelle de
Schopenhauer il a soif de reconnaissance
il veut imposer ses idées après son
ambition ne l'empêche pas d'être sincère
par exemple il dit beaucoup de bien de
l'autre géant de la philosophie
allemande de l'époque quand même s'il
prétend corriger la théorie de la
connaissance de Kant shopenhauer estime
qu'elle est géniale et que c'est un
passage obligé pour comprendre le monde
voici une phrase qu'on trouve dans le
carnet secret de Schopenhauer je suis
celui qui a écrit le monde comme volonté
comme représentation et qui a apporté
une solution au grand problème de
l'existence et il le dit même sans
détour à son éditeur ce livre que au
prix d'un grand labeur j'ai rendu
accessible à la compréhension des autres
sera selon ma ferme conviction un de
ceux qui deviendront la source et
l'occasion de 100 autres livres ah oui
il est vraiment sûr de lui il sait que
ce livre va être un carton mais voilà
dans la réalité pas dans l'imagination
de l'auteur le livre qui a résolu le
grand problème de l'existence fait un
bide il passe presque inaperçu seul si
critique paraissent dans les deux
premières années 300 exemplaires en tout
se vendront en 30 ans les rares lecteurs
trouvent que shopenhaware s'exprime avec
clarté et éloquence mais ils ne sont pas
convaincus par ses idées après comme il
n'a que 31 ans à l'apparition de la
première édition il a le temps de tout
reprendre et de retenter sa chance mais
chopenhauer ne perdra jamais confiance
dans sa pensée donc il ne modifiera
jamais c'était fondamental il ne fera
que les simplifier les clarifier et les
étendre du coup comme il déjà exprimé
l'essentiel de sa pensée il propose ses
services de traducteurs aux maisons
d'édition pour traduire goet en Français
et en Anglais pour traduire David Yume
le philosophe écossais en allemand et la
même proposé de réaliser des traductions
en italien mais à cause de son caractère
et de son ego les tractations avec les
éditeurs n'aboutissent jamais on peut
tirer deux choses de cette anecdote sur
le chef-d'oeuvre de Schopenhauer tout
d'abord je peux avoir est vraiment
sincère il écrit ce qu'il pense et il
n'est pas prêt à travestir sa pensée
pour séduire le public ensuite l'échec
du livre dans lequel il a mis toute sa
pensée et toute son âme c'est un peu
comme un divorce entre lui et le monde
et le fait qu'il connaisse un tel échec
si jeune ne peut que renforcer la
propension à la dépression qu'il a
hérité de son père
un jour épuisé après avoir rédigé une
longue lettre schopenhawer renverse
l'encre sur le sol alors il appelle sa
servante pour qu'il s'en occupe et en
frottant le sol elle lui dit qu'elle a
rêvé la nuit précédente qu'elle allait
faire ça sceptique Schopenhauer lui
demande une preuve ça tombe bien elle a
déjà parlé de son rêve à une autre
servante qui vient confirmer ce n'est
pas le seul fait surnaturel consigné par
shopenhauer il a lui-même fait des rêves
prémonitoires et cela depuis l'enfance
vers le milieu de la trentaine il
s'intéresse au paranormal le magnétisme
les fantômes la clairvoyance les
prophéties la communication avec les
morts etc il accepte l'authenticité de
ces phénomènes parce qu'ils sont
universels ils se sont produits dans
toutes les cultures en tout temps et en
tout lieu en particulier comme beaucoup
de monde depuis les aventures de Messmer
à la fin du XVIIIe siècle Schopenhauer
creuse le sujet de l'hypnose il assiste
à des séances l'attitude et le discours
des personnes qui sont en état de transe
l'impression non seulement shopenhauer
accepte la réalité de l'hypnose mais il
en induit que ce que l'on appelle la
magie correspond à des phénomènes réels
il est conscient que le domaine du
paranormal est plein d'escrocs qui
gagnent leur vie en abusant de la
crédulité des gens mais il pense qu'il
existe des personnes avec d'authentique
pouvoir surnaturels donc il va expliquer
ces phénomènes de telle manière à les
rendre compatibles avec son système
philosophique cette anecdote montre que
shopenhauer est animé par une curiosité
sans borne étant donné qu'il a
l'ambition de comprendre l'expérience
humaine dans son intégralité dans toutes
ses dimensions il est ouvert à tous les
sujets
un compositeur a raconté la conversation
qu'il a eu avec shopenhauer alors de la
trentaine au cours d'un dîner à
Francfort le philosophe lui dit avec
enthousiasme que la science a réalisé la
plus grande découverte en trouvant
comment satisfaire les besoins de la
nature en évitant l'infection il lui
décrit alors la solution il faut
dissoudre une portion de chlorure de
chaude dans de l'eau puis il suffit d'y
baigner l'appareil masculin après l'acte
sexuel c'est une découverte importante
pour chaponaware parce qu'il a été très
embêté au cours du dernier trimestre de
l’année 1823 il a suivi un traitement
intensif pour le débarrasser de la
syphilis il avait très probablement
contracté cette maladie en fréquentant
en les bordels ce qui était courant pour
les hommes de la bourgeoisie de cette
époque et du coup l'enjeu pour lui
c'était de rester sexuellement actif
sans risquer l'infection shopenhaware
tire simplement les conséquences de sa
philosophie l'amour est un piège que la
nature nous attendu pour nous
contraindre à nous reproduire toute
passion et critique dans sa métaphysique
de l'amour quelque apparence éthérée
qu'elle se donne à sa racine dans
l'instinct sexuel donc je peux Nour
satisfait directement l'instinct sexuel
sans se laisser remporter dans
l'illusion de la passion amoureuse mais
ça c'est la théorie dans les faits son
rapport à l'amour est bien plus
compliqué d'un côté il voit les femmes
comme des objets sexuels il va au bordel
il multiplie les relations
occasionnelles avec des femmes de
conditions sociales inférieures il a
quelques relations plus sérieuses mais
sans perspective d'engagement au début
de la trentaine le philosophe met une
servante enceinte ce qui désole sa sœur
la domestique accouchera d'une petite
fille qui mourra dans les premiers mois
il n'est pas impossible que le rapport
de chaponaware aux femmes lui viennent
de son père en effet sa mère raconte
dans ses mémoires que son mari avait lu
beaucoup de littérature érotique et
quand il avait vécu en France et elle
estime que c'est à cause de cette
influence qu'il réduisait les femmes à
des objets sexuels mais shopenhauer lui
est capable de sentiment il confesse
dans une lettre à un ami d'enfance qu'il
a été très amoureux d'une femme qui la
fréquenté pendant des années mais que
l'histoire a mal fini quand elle n'a pas
tenu sa promesse de quitter Berlin avec
lui comme souvent la vérité des actes
s'écarte des paroles dans les dernières
années de sa vie shopenhauer décourage
fortement un de Stéphane un avocat à
trentenaire d'épouser la femme qu'il
aime il lui rappelle comment sa mère à
négliger son père malade dans les
derniers mois de sa vie mais
schovenhauer lui avait pensé plusieurs
fois à se marier au même âge ce qu'il
faut tirer de cette anecdote c'est que
la misogynie de Schopenhauer traduit
l'état d'esprit qu'il habitait au moment
où il écrivait le texte d'un côté il
n'était pas parti avec les meilleurs
cartes pour être heureux en amour sa
mère n'aimait pas son père elle ne
semble pas non plus l'avoir
véritablement aimé lui son fils il
n'était pas à bel homme il a connu des
déceptions aux amoureuses et ces
propositions de mariage ont été refusés
mais de l'autre côté contrairement à
d'autres grands philosophes il a eu une
vie sexuelle et une vie amoureuse
[Musique]
un livre de vulgarisation qui n'est pas
écrit pour le monde académique mais pour
un lectorat bien plus large shopenhauer
il parle de beaucoup de sujets
différents dans un style clair et
éloquent donc c'est très accessible et
puis il y a beaucoup d'attaques par
exemple contre les profs de philo et ça
ça plaît au public une autre raison du
succès ce sont les comptes rendus au
début les pareras et poméla se vendent
très lentement parce que shopenhauer est
inconnu mais les critiques qui sont des
faiseurs d'opinion des couples l'intérêt
pour le livre en disant du bien enfin il
y a aussi le rôle des fans de
shopenhauer pendant plusieurs décennies
les idées du philosophe avaient
progressivement conquis des esprits peut
au sein du monde académique bien
davantage au sein de la bourgeoisie
d'affaires les fans de Schopenhauer sont
des hommes pratiques solides qui ont
réussi dans la vie pas mal d'avocats
notamment et la particularité de ces
fans c'est que la philosophie de
shopenhauer a changé leur vie ils disent
qu'elle a eu sur eux l'effet d'une
révélation religieuse du coup ils sont
eux-mêmes des prosélythes ils diffusent
la doctrine de leur maître à penser je
peux avoir se rend compte que ces fans
le regardent comme un prophète ça le
gêne un peu mais il a attendu
reconnaissance pendant tellement
longtemps qu'il laisse faire il jouit de
sa popularité tous les journalistes tous
les critiques tous les auteurs parlent
de lui les gens le reconnaissent dans la
rue ils le regardent avec curiosité au
restaurant il lui demande des
autographes et lui envoie des cadeaux il
est même devenu une attraction
touristique à Francfort ça notoriété à
tir à lui des femmes remarquables aussi
intelligentes que belle par exemple il
tombe sous le charme de la sculptrice de
26 ans qui vient le rencontrer pour
réaliser son buste alors que shopenhauer
a écrit un des pires pamphlets misogynes
de l'histoire de la pensée une
admiratrice rapporte qui lui aurait dit
oh je n'ai pas dit mon dernier mot sur
les femmes
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu que vous avez découvert des
choses intéressantes et même inspirantes
sur shopenhauer si c'est le cas donnez
un pouce bleu à la vidéo et puis laissez
un commentaire pour améliorer leur
référencement de la vidéo ce n’est pas
grand chose et puis ça m'aide vraiment
je suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
Aristote et vous vous étiez sur le
millier de culture générale
rappelez-vous vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée j'ai
une question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parle bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
et oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et
les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
Ronan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les 5
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les 5 secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tranquille sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez